he was good at that
to
look at shot
he'll be there
Walker leans in
[Applause]
take a look at it it's gone right her
kick down
[Applause]
bodies carefree to the time thanks
right here Oh fake Beasley sidestep we
saw that down a sidestep knock down a
three late in the game when he needs it
kip-up
Butler thinks he's got it a quick step
back high over the top of Butler and
it's Saturday night yeah the banks are
open in Uptown and 15 is cashing it in
really unfortunate that would be a foul
and the basket what a shot Kimball
Walker's knees so watch this he's
off-balance boom we're not gonna be able
to see it so far I think it's the right
knee 11 shots total in the first half
shot clock down to three
[Applause]
[Music]
Walker fires away any hits at a
three-pointer
from downtown it's a four-point name the
points for Walker step back Jay here the
sideline money
trying to force a game seven here
tonight Walker
betrayed
[Applause]
so tomb on the drives Gilchrist
tough catch it's Walker Carter on a
flyby into three and down the road
for Kemba Walker what do you make of
that well I think this birds are locked
in on them and you can see they've been
a nice job that going to be his time
coming down the stretch
[Applause]
Kemba down
[Applause]
[Music]
no call looks at this and says okay
you're not going to get up in time when
I knock this down right here what it's
have to hurry step back for Kent bomb
and that falls
jock maquette 7 trying to make a move
here it's gone what a bucket by kept the
Walker believable shot right here Yuma
Cory Joseph draped all over him Walker
steps back for three the assist park is
a new career-high Walker is sometimes
what fellatio the spin cycle
we'll shoot me with a skip and Kim
Milwaukee stops on a dime
steps back watches it go through amber
on door C screen by Zeller stop starts
fires toner all back-to-back triples for
the Captain Walker for a three
[Music]
a gigantic three-pointer our home record
is in jeopardy you can feel his
confidence growing even on the road
timba usual [ __ ] right here Kemba
bounces into a three
[Applause]
patience the stream set by Cody smart
for some reason chance to go under the
screen that leads out Horford on an
island as a shot clocks winding up is
how the mix is going to be in the second
half of the season it's the three as the
buzzer sounds they're gonna check it out
but he clearly got it off in time shots
but Charlotte has attempted 62 two
pointers the Nets have attempted 36
threes and there's Walker with a 3-ball
we think Joe wolf is running the same
type of offensive defensive schemes that
Coach Greco is here at home more often
loves the offensive schemes of coach JB
and that's why he's in the game strictly
to do that and get some points on the
board
[Applause]
classic
whoa stop reversed between the leg
gerbils melting pretty good jump
[Music]
Kemba readjusts and splashes it classic
Kemba Walker change the often slow down
a little bit no not yet
today's have a second half he had
marketing let first step back he said
now I'm gonna do it a little cleaner
- pow pow pow
[Applause]
three-parter guess we shouldn't be
surprised to juice to 42% indeed
qualities where he's like it's neat
[Applause]
[Applause]
the averages nine and a half assists per
game
JimBob up and down for number 15 his
first triple devil Walker's with
Kaminsky try to break it off step back
three got it
guys got so much game 102 99 huh
back up back up three-ball South's get a
chance to reboot down to 9 on the shot
clock
camera step back trees
at fourth quarter it is Kimmel Walker
it's going to have to be the guy John
ion comes out to defend him Walker
but reheat this Oh miss avoids me he has
no space pump fakes
leaves board knows how to walk or
keeping a good [ __ ] alive Paul defended
five on the shot clock
[Applause]
who
man had to get to this body warning off
shop Kemba Walker
Walker little dance man goes by
whose big shots by the Celtics at the
end on the first and second court Walker
by Campbell just drives hard here in a
second to get shot up moving his feet
ooh
like you said gray some ankles drop them
off and knocks down that three